이번 질문은 뭡니까?
3시 20분에 거래를 하려고 들어갔는데
거래가 안 되고 정지가 돼 있더라고요.
맞아 맞아. 끊겨.
그건 왜 그런지 이 세상이 억가하는 것 같습니다.
나 다시 꺼낼게.
자 우리나라 주식시장은 9시에서 15시 30분까지 장이 열립니다.
여기 근처에 장이 멈춰요.
한국거래소 기준으로 8시 30분에서 9시까지는 오전에 동시효과라는 걸 합니다.
동시효과? 동시에 부르는 가격?
자 그거를 이해하기 위해서 캔들 보죠. 캔들.
자 이렇게 쓰여있는 빨간색 봉이 있다고 봅시다.
A, B, C, D가 있습니다.
시가가 어디예요?
A?
빨간색이...
아닌가? 빨간색 양봉이에요?
자네 미국장 하다 왔어요.
제가 미국장 하고 계십니다.
아 외국에서 오셨군요.
초록색으로 봐봅니다.
초록색으로? 오케이 오케이.
시작가는 여기가 B입니다.
여기서 시작한 거예요.
아 처음 알았습니다. 진짜.
이 캔들은 도대체 어떻게 본 거예요? 그럼 지금까지.
사실 숫자만 보고 거래하지 않습니다.
숫자님이 대충 삼성전자 사라 이러면 눈 감고 삼성전자 클리어.
이게 유치원의 현실입니다.
여기서 시작을 합니다.
어제가 만원이었어요.
근데 오늘은 1% 올랐네요.
여기가 만 백원이네요.
플러스 1%.
여기서 오늘 시작을 했어요.
시가가 1% 뛰어서 시작한 거예요.
아까 전에 제가 8시 반에서 9시 사이에 동시효과라는 게 있다 그랬어요.
자 이걸 왜 만드냐?
어제 이 주식이 만원에 끝났어요.
근데 밤에 좋은 일이 있었어.
막 달려?
엔비디아 달려 막 달려.
그러면 아침에 사고 싶죠?
엄청 사고 싶습니다.
자 그럼 어저께 끝난 만원에 살려고 사람들이 줄을 쓸 거 아니에요.
무조건 오를 테니까.
그럼 누가 만원에 팝니까?
안 팔죠.
이런 식으로 매수 매도 효과 창이 있잖아요.
익숙하시죠?
이건 팔자 효과, 여긴 사자 효과.
어떤 사람들은 야 이거 어제 시장 보니까 시장 많이 올랐어.
나는 팔자는 여기에 팔고 싶어.
하지만 난 여기에 사고 싶어.
그러다가 사람들이 시장 가까이에다 보면 에에나 모르겠다.
그래 나는 팔고 싶어.
난 가격을 좀 낮춰서 팔게.
여기도 판다.
그러면 이들의 접점을
찾아서 그게 예를 들면 만 200원이다.
플러스 2% 만 200원에서 시작하는 겁니다.
이 8시 8에서 9시 사이에 모여서 이거를 하는 거예요.
자 그런데 어디에 결정하는지도 알아야 되거든요.
어떤 사람은 만 500원이어서 살 생각이 있어요.
하지만 이미 팔자들이 많기 때문에
만 200원까지 내려가도 팔 사람이 있으면
나는 여기다가 넣었지만 만 200원에 살 수 있습니다.
팔자도 나는 9,800원에 팔 생각이 있어요.
사자가 많아. 만 200원까지 사자가 있어.
그럼 난 여기다 넣었지만 만 200원에 팔게 됩니다.
어 그러면 완전 높게 계속 호가해버리면 되는 거 아닙니까?
그러면은
어 사자가 없어요.
그럼 진짜 완전 높게
만 500원에 실제 사게 되는
예측치 못한 타격이 있을 수 있죠.
그럼 가격을 왜 높게 넣냐.
이유가 있습니다.
동시효과에는 내가 얼마가 넣는지가 안 보여요.
아무것도 안 움직이고 있는데 제가 넣는 거군요.
그쵸 아무것도 안 움직이고 있는데
안 보이는데 서로 넣는 거예요.
땅 하고 다닐까에 결정되는 겁니다.
1번 높은 가격을 쓴 사람이 먼저 사게 되고
2번 수량을 많이 써놓으면은 또 우선권이 있습니다.
만 200원에 어떤 사람은 한 주 사겠다고 써왔어.
어떤 사람들은 천 주야.
그럼 천 주를 먼저 배정해줘요.
높은 가격을 쓸수록 많이 쓸수록 배정을 해줍니다.
자 그래서 결정을 하는데 그게 뭐다?
시가다.
이게 소위 경매 비슷한 거예요 사실.
수산시장 가면 이렇게 하잖아요.
9만 원입니까?
9,800원, 9,200원, 9,400원
어? 500원, 500원 없습니까? 없습니까?
9시 땡!
9,500원 낙찰!
아...
그럼 그 아래 사겠다고 한 사람은 못 사는 거고
그 위에 사겠다고 한 사람들만 사지는 거예요.
자 그러면 요건 뭐냐.
주가가 여기서 시작했어.
근데 내려갔다가 올라가는 거예요.
시가는 여긴데 내려간 점이 여기.
그래서 여기를 그날에...
저가라 그럽니다.
D는 뭐겠습니까 당연히?
최고점! 고가!
그럼 요건 뭐예요?
종가!
그래요. 이게 종가입니다.
이게 무슨 소리냐면
여기서 시작했네? 시작가에서
내려갔네? 저가 찍었죠?
근데 쭉 올라갔어요. 고가예요.
근데 종가가 여기서 끝난 거예요.
여기가 시가, 여기가 저가, 여기가 고가, 여기가 종가가 되는 겁니다.
이게 한 번에 표현하니까 이런 모습이 나오는 거예요.
그러면 종가가 고가면 둘이 합쳐져 있습니까?
그렇죠!
그러면은 이런 모습이 되는 거예요.
종가와 고가가 같다.
자, 쉽습니까?
네, 여기까지는 쉽습니다.
우리 유치원 반이니까 아주 쉬운 심화학습을 해볼게요.
빨간봉만 있는 게 아니라 이렇게 파란봉도 있을 수 있어요.
시가가 어디예요?
B요.
B가 시가죠.
종가는 어디예요?
시요.
여기가 종가죠.
여기가 고가, 여기가 저가예요.
왜 파란색이 된 겁니까?
시가에 비해서 종가가 내려가서 파란색으로 표현한 거예요.
아까 빨간색은 종가가 어디였어요?
여기였잖아요.
색깔을 굳이 입히는 이유가 종가가 어딘지 보라는 겁니다.
색깔이 없으면 어디서 끝난 건지, 어디서 시작한 건지 모르잖아요.
지금까지 얘기했던 그 종가라는 거 그것도 결정해야 되잖아요.
종가는 어떻게 결정합니까?
3시 20분부터 30분 사이에도 동시효과가 있습니다.
그렇죠.
아까 전에 동시효과가 앞에만 있지 않고 언젠가 있다고 그랬어요.
3시 20분에서 3시 30분까지 시장이 멈춰요.
여러분들은 이걸 보고 아까 질문을 하는 겁니다.
20분이 뭐라는 겁니까?
이 종가를 정하는 경매를 하는 겁니다.
근데 굳이 왜 안 보여줘요?
왜냐하면 마지막에 장난질을 하거든요.
15시 29분.
55초 할 때.
누가 위로 쫙 서면 그거 딱 끝나잖아요.
종가 장난질이 가능하잖아요.
주식의 가격에 따라서 많은 사람들의 이해가 걸려있는 상품들이 많기 때문에
이거를 합리적으로 결정해야 되는 룰이 필요한 겁니다.
지금까지 제가 말씀드린 거는 KRX.
우리나라 한국 거래소 기준이에요.
사실 얼마 전까지 그냥 이것만 얘기했으면 끝났어요.
근데 요즘에 뭐가 있습니까? 요즘에?
넥스트장.
NXT가 있죠.
우리나라 옛날에는 단일 거래소였어요.
한국 거래소만 있었어요.
근데 2022년에 넥스트 트레이드가 생겼어요.
넥장이 생겼죠, 소위.
그래서 지금은 거래 시간이 더 늘었죠.
0, 8시에서 20시까지 하죠.
여러분들은 사실은 이 체제에서 느끼는 거는
앞에 빨리 시작했고 뒤에 길게 한다.
장 중에는 잘 못 느껴요.
왜냐? 여러분들이 효과를 넣으면
증권회사들이 자동으로 유리한 가격을 체결해줘요.
그러니까 두 개를 통합한 시스템으로 운용을 많이 합니다.
아, 그러면 제가 샀는데 넥장에서 샀을 수도 있겠네요?
거기 보면은 KLX 플러스 NXT라고 내는 체크하는 데들이 있어요.
본장과는 상관없는 장이라고 보면 됩니다.
위를 본장이라고 얘기를 할게요.
말 그대로 여러분들끼리 모여서
사업하는 건 자유야.
본장의 가격에 영향을 미치지 않아요.
물론 영향을 미치죠, 사람들이.
어, 넥장에서 저렇게 올랐구나.
그러면 그 다음날 시가가 높게 시작하겠죠.
살짝 헤네시스 자유시장 같은 느낌이네.
그쵸, 자유시장하고 비슷해요.
앞에 있는 시장에서 막 움직였는데
KLX는 9시 땡 시작하잖아요.
두 개 가격 차이가 다르면 어떡해?
이 다르면 이거 샀다 팔았다 하면서
비싼 거 팔고 싼 거 사면 되잖아.
이런 생각을 할 수 있어요.
그래서 넥장도 어떻게 됩니까?
이 시간쯤 되면 멈춥니다.
그래서 멈춰요.
그래서 여기 시가가 딱 찍히는 걸 보고 같이 열립니다.
자, 끝날 때도 마찬가지예요.
넥장도 같이 멈춥니다.
그러면 살짝 넥장에서 하는 거는
호구당하기 쉬울 수도 있겠네요.
넥장은 거래량이 적고
호가가 얇기 때문에
거래가 막 튀고 막 내려갈 수 있어요.
그래서 가끔 사고 나요.
삼성전자 차트에 이렇게 하다가
이렇게 된 때가 있어요.
요즘은 이제 거기까지 올라갔잖아요, 가격이.
이게 왜 생겼냐?
이런 넥장 같은 데서 호가 얇을 때
비싼 가격에 사자를 넣는데
매수 가격이 중간에 없어가지고
높은 가격에 하나 딱 체결된 거예요.
실수라는 거죠.
소위 말해 손가락이 두껍다,
패핑거라 그러는데
나는 만 원 사자에 넣어야지 하고
만 원에 주문을 넣는데
손가락이 두꺼워서 이걸 10만 원이라고 쓴 거예요.
그럼 여기는 호가 다 잡아먹고 올라가는 거 아니에요.
쩌에 위에 누가 올려놓은 거 하나 탁 거래된 겁니다.
아, 그럼 저 말은 누가 저기에 올려놨다는 말이네요?
아침마다 올려온 사람 있어요.
실수를 노리고.
주식시장에 환불이 있죠.
시가로 해드립니다.
아.
이 가격에 환불해줘요.
시가가 시작가라는 것도 처음 알았어요.
시장가인 줄 알았어요, 저는.
시작가는 말 그대로
그날 빵 떠서 아니면 빵 내려가서 시작하는
그 시작가 여기잖아요.
그걸 시가라 그래요.
시장가는 뭐냐면
매매할 때 받습니다, 시장가로.
이거 누르면 큰일 날 수 있어요.
가격이 쭉 있고 거래가 걸려 있잖아요.
매도 물량이 예를 들면 10주
중간에 호가가 오고 쫙
한 300원에 누가 여기다가 100주 매도를 걸어놨어.
50주 살래요, 시장가에.
그럼 30주까지 적절하게 사줬는데
나머지 20주는 1,300원에 엄청나게 비싼 가격에 사줘.
그래서 아까 전에 삼성전자 차트 같은
이런 차트가 나오는 겁니다.
시장가 매수도 있고 시장가 매도도 있어요.
매도는 이제 반대라고 보시면 돼요.
빨리 팔 거면 시장가 매도로 그냥 싹
시장가 매수로 팍 쳤더니
가격이 확 없어지면서
초!
갑자기 또 지하에서 팔리고
그래서 어지간하면 지정가 매수, 지정가 매도가 필요합니다.
그래서 장 끝날 때 특히 시장이 왜 멈추느냐
종가를 결정하기 위해서다.
그리고 오전에 동시화권 들어가면서
또 시가라는 거를 결정을 한다.
8시에서 이제는 밤 8시까지 거래를 할 수 있게 됐다.
결국에는 너네 더 거래 많이 해줄게의 취지인 거잖아요, 그렇죠?
왜냐하면 우리나라는 해가 뜨기 시작해.
우리나라 시장이 막 돌아가요.
그다음에 메인장이 유럽장이에요.
그다음에 메인장이 이렇게 돌아서기는 미국장입니다.
그러면 우리나라 장 끝날 때
이게 연결돼서 시작이 돼야 되는데
이게 빈단 말이에요, 장 딱 끝난 다음에.
야, 이때까지 거래해야 되지 않을까?
뭐 이런 생각을 한다는 겁니다.
연결성은 왜 필요한 겁니까?
꼭 필요하다고 할 수는 없는데
사람들이 불편해할 수도 있고
외국인들이 연결성이 약하게 생각할 수도 있죠.
다른 시장하고 연결되게
쭉 거래할 수 있게 하자는 요구들이 상당히 많았습니다.
그런 게 이제 영향을 미쳤습니다.
요즘에 우리나라 코스피의 가장 큰 화두가
뭐예요?
외국인들이 너무 많이 판다는 거죠.
왜 팔겠습니까?
멍청해요.
한국말 몰라서 아직 배우고 있어.
또 방에 안 들어가 봤어.
올라가는 걸 몰랐어?
더 갈 줄 몰랐어요.
우리 미모의 강사가 두 분 계십니다.
이니 쌤으로 유명하신
전 유치원을 졸업하고
지금 중학교에
아니에요, 유치원을 자퇴했어요.